yeah that was nice what kind of dog is
that
it's a mutt
i don't know it's a whole bunch of we
thought it was a multi-poo like we were
specifically getting a multi-poo and
then i did one of those dna tests like
the doggy dna test and it's not it's
everything it's mixed with like it's
mostly italian it's 80 italian right
yeah
is any part of it native any native
american 23 and me
he did that for dogs have you done that
test no chance why i would never send my
blood to a private company why what is
your favorite why
why
why
why would i send my blood my dna to a
private company that gets to keep it
then in perpetuity for the rest of time
first of all it's not your blood i did
it it's your okay it's your dna
which is the same thing your dna is what
i'm referring to the dna in your blood
your urine whatever i don't want a
private corporation to have that why in
the medical field i'm fine with it
because if i'm going to a doctor and we
need to diagnose something because a
private company then has your dna in
perpetuity that's a little strange why
do they want your dna
well
and what could they do with it literally
they can tell you what your ancestry is
they could also use your dna for
research for
that you have to give them when you
submit it you have to give them
permission to use your dna for research
so you have to sign something if you
want it if you don't want them using
your dna for any research then you don't
sign it do you think they're really
listening to that
yeah i do but what is your in your worst
case scenario what is your worst fear
that they would do
imagine they use your dna
to to start cloning people or submitting
your dna for
unsolved crimes
and they start throwing in you a mix of
also just using it illegally i just get
scared of like why would my dna
be valuable to a private company and
there's a reason for sure they're doing
it because they want to collect dna
we think it's because they want to tell
us what our heritage is but i don't
believe that
i get very suspicious of a company
collecting human dna
i know they were also using i'm
definitely a conspiracy theorist are you
100 i think we have one here too jeremy
yeah do you agree with that jeremy
completely agrees here uh yeah i kind of
do
why do you kinda get all in dude don't
put a foot in the hot tub go in i do not
kind of yeah because it because a
private corporation that has no
government regulation that's a little
sketchy to me
it's a little sketchy for them to harbor
your dna forever that's like
they can do whatever they want with it
even though jackie's like i didn't sign
a paper it's like that will never hold
up
after time they'll already have done
what they wanted to do so what if they
cloned me and make me like a super
soldier
how awful why because once we start
playing god we're all dead
once we start cloning they've already
cloned for sure right she's a clone
you know that right
the redhead the follower caroline i've
met caroline ten times already today
no just this year though
are you a clone
i might be a stalker
[Music]